are you okay
okay
the town of hawkins isn't exactly the
safest place to live in and some of that
danger carried into the real-life
production of stranger things these are
the scenes that were dangerous and
difficult for the actors to film
if you're little
and you're scared of stuff do not maybe
watch the season get watch it with an
adult number one
millie bobby brown had to do a lot of
spinning for this season 3 scene during
the scene when she is in the void with
billy her character falls backwards
after escaping billy's grip it seems
like a simple stunt but the behind the
scenes execution of this scene was
dizzying millie was hooked into a rig
that spun her around and around and
around after doing the same shot
multiple times and spinning over and
over again the nauseating experience
actually made millie throw up afterwards
and how can anyone blame her that looked
more intense than any theme park ride
number two
look at hot enough 220 degrees we just
have to figure out how to get him in
here while the sauna scene in season
three was meant to show billy burning up
the actual filming of the scene had
everyone on set dealing with the heat
the director of the episode sean levy
stated that there were 100 people
present that day on a small set that was
very tight and that he got over a
hundred different angles of the scene
things got so intense during filming
that millie bobby brown actually
collapsed due to exhaustion during the
scene and that shot is in the show finn
wolfhard caught her and had no idea what
to do you can actually see him looking
off screen for help in the final cut as
he was genuinely concerned for her
safety their commitment to the scene
paid off as the raw energies showed up
on screen
number three
the finale of season three was an
emotional rollercoaster and no scene was
more powerful than when eleven read
hopper's note to her to ensure they got
the best most raw reaction possible
millie made sure not to read the speech
beforehand she wanted to know absolutely
nothing about it she didn't even
rehearse the scene i just immediately
wanted to put a camera on me and find
the way i react and the way i reacted
was pure devastation and sadness so the
emotions were raw in that scene for sure
on top of this they also had to film the
farewell scene with everybody she said
they imagined it was the end of filming
forever and everyone started crying when
the cameras started rolling it sounds
like it was a very somber day on set
hey
[Music]
it's gonna be okay
number four
the final showdown of season three ended
in the star court mall and at one point
saw billy pinning down eleven as he was
being controlled by the mind flayer this
was a difficult scene to film both
physically and mentally millie bobby
brown noted the scene as one of the most
difficult because the two actors needed
to figure out how they were going to
play the scene with the level of
intensity they usually bring daker
montgomery was conscientious when it
came to not hurting millie during the
scene but he also wanted to bring his
usual level of intensity if you want to
know how dedicated these two actors are
to their craft they said they would run
around the mall screaming until they
cried and we both lost our voices
because and we don't even speak in the
scene but we were just screaming at each
other sean levy described the pair as
two of our most powerful actors
number five
daker montgomery and millie bobby
brown's intensity didn't stop at that
one scene they were bringing their
intense energy to every single scene
they filmed together even if there's no
screaming in a certain scene i'd scream
between takes and so would millie we'd
scream at each other until we cried
baker described the experience of
filming with millie as a significant
mental challenge and said that they both
gave 200 into every scene they did
together montgomery was screaming so
much throughout the course of filming
that he lost his voice nearly every day
it sounds like the dynamic between dager
and millie was truly special
number six
let's keep rolling with dager
montgomery's extreme intensity on set
during the sonos scene in season three
when the kids trap billy montgomery took
his intensity to a whole new level and
may have gone a little too far in the
scene his character billy is supposed to
taunt and yell at the kids through the
door that's what was shown in the final
cut but there was a much angrier take
montgomery actually headbutted the glass
window and did so with such force that
his head actually broke through the
glass the glass was thick and not
designed to break so it was a shocking
moment to say the least and the kids
reacted with horror it was a very
dangerous moment and it was physically
exhausting as well i put everything that
i had into it but luckily montgomery
wasn't hurt still he was hoping the take
would make the final cut imagine my
disappointment when that take wasn't
used
number seven
another scene another example of daker
montgomery's commitment to giving it 200
each and every take during the shower
scene in season three montgomery was so
physically and emotionally invested that
he didn't even realize he had covered
himself in scrapes and bruises he
learned later on in the day when he took
off his makeup and prosthetics to
discover the injuries one particularly
gross memory he recounted was peeling
the skin off the top of his toes
i said are you hurt
what's going on i heard screaming his
commitment to his character is truly
impressive
number eight
yet another emotionally taxing scene
took place in season 2 when 11 has a
confrontation with hopper and we went
through so many different emotions we
get angry at each other we are like we
are like father and daughter it also
sounded like the whole experience was
therapeutic for the actors as brown
stated that arguing wasn't limited to
just on camera we got angry with each
other and we would express our feelings
on and off the set david harbour also
had a cathartic experience filming these
emotionally demanding scenes it was a
sort of unlocking in me as a human being
of like a love that was uh human but
that was pure number nine
will's possession scene in season two
wasn't the most fun experience for noah
schnapp he had to wear black contacts
throughout the day of shooting which
burned his eyes and he was nervous to
have to perform the seizure part of the
scene it was really scary you kind of
just lock up and i had to prepare for
that a lot on top of this it was
actually pretty cold on set the heaters
you see didn't actually work to heat up
the room it was winter during shooting
and noah's clothing was not optimal and
the cherry on top is that noah joined
the ranks of his co-stars as someone who
lost their voice due to screaming during
a scene
number 10
when eleven closes the gate during the
season two finale there is a lot of
screaming and intensity it was a
difficult scene for millie bobby brown
to get through as it required her to be
lifted into the air on a crane while
yelling non-stop in between takes millie
would have to recompose herself because
the scene made her nauseous i'd have to
like take a breather throw up a little
then come back inside do it again
luckily for her the ever lovely david
harbour was right there by her side to
help out even offering her bracelets
that supposedly would help her nausea
number 11
entering the void isn't as easy as 11
makes it look millie bobby brown was
actually floating in a pool filled with
salt for this scene in season 1. it
actually seems pretty peaceful but it
was a different story on set it was
freezing cold the day they shot this and
millie had no help staying warm in that
pool the crew tried heating the pool but
it was to no avail as it was too shallow
to retain any of the heat fortunately
for them millie was a trooper braving
the cold to get the scene done
number 12
when 11 is in chicago with kali and
tregang cauley puts the image of papa
into her mind and 11 is confronted by
him this was another very emotionally
draining scene from millie she got so
into it that even after cut was called
the emotions of the scene were still
running through her after filming was
done she went into the bathroom and
cried for about 45 minutes
number 13. a first kiss for anyone is
nerve-wracking let alone having to do it
in front of cameras and an audience
sadie sink and caleb mclaughlin both had
their first kiss during the school dance
scene at the end of season 2. sadie was
actually told about the kissing scene
the day before it was going to happen as
it was never in the script the duffer
brothers revealed they were initially
joking when they told her but decided to
do the kiss for real when they saw how
strongly sadie reacted to make things a
thousand times worse there were a ton of
people watching just to guarantee
maximum awkwardness my first kiss was in
front of like two women
and their parents and the crew and my
mom number 14.
sadie and caleb weren't the only two
that kissed that day right before they
did their kissing scene finn wolfhard
and millie bobby brown shared a kiss of
their own they had already kissed in
season one but that didn't stop this
moment from being very awkward as we
know the set was full of people watching
on top of this wolfard stated that the
gym they were filming in was very hot to
make things even weirder all the extras
clapped after they kissed talk about
uncomfortable at least wolfhard warned
millie before going for the kiss he was
like okay i'm coming in number 15.
as we've learned millie bobby brown has
done a lot of screaming during her time
playing the character 11. however season
3 was a particularly scream filled
season for millie she stated that she
lost her voice 5 times over the 8 months
she was filming but just because filming
was over didn't mean the screaming was
too millie was brought back into the
recording booth to record additional
lines and dub over the ones she already
did this meant screaming all over again
i was screaming so much during the shoot
usually
but she doesn't like this voice
it sure does sound like filming for
stranger things was an intense
experience did you know millie bobby
brown tore her kneecap while filming for
stranger things season 3 was still
ongoing it didn't happen on set but did
affect the production she ended up
needing a stunt double to fill in for a
lot of her scenes this year we have
taken the most time out of anyone but it
is the best season yet the stranger
things cast and crew have had to deal
with their fair share of incredibly
painful prosthetics and costumes over
the years and season 4 is no stranger to
that it's one of the most painful
seasons yet ready to find out why it's a
dark dark season for me number one nine
hours in the makeup chair plus 12 hours
of acting plus an hour and a half back
out of makeup you don't have to be good
at math to know jamie wasn't sleeping
okay 9 hours is exaggerating while it
initially took that long they managed to
get it down to 6 hours and 20 minutes
with a team of four working on jamie
campbell bauer non-stop jamie donned
roughly 25 prosthetics that were glued
to his skin every day and the thing is
they weren't reusable so they ended up
having roughly 25 copies of 25
prosthetics that's over 600 prosthetic
pieces it's me underneath the
prosthetics it's my voice it's me moving
barry gower said we would spend the best
part of five hours just purely gluing
the appliances onto his skin then we'd
have an hour and a half of airbrushing
and joining all the dots together with
the paintwork and airbrushing veins and
blending everything when sadie sink
first saw him she couldn't stop laughing
because she was so creeped out and
unsettled the prosthetic was roughly 90
practical the only thing added in post
was those pulsing veins so it makes
sense why it freaked her out
number two teeny tiny ear holes make for
difficult creature acting trying to get
the voice for vechna was problematic
thanks to the prosthetics
jamie campbell bower said i was in adr
for the show a couple of weeks ago and
the engineer was like i've got this
octave for you by that the engineer
meant a voice distorter bower's response
was oh no we don't use that the engineer
didn't believe him and so he did the
voice and so says bower the engineer
said right yep i've cancelled the octave
of that it's off now but it was much
harder when they were filming versus
being in the booth because the suit goes
over the ears and the ear holes are
incredibly tiny it was quite difficult
and distorted trying to hear himself
speak
number three when will they leave dakor
alone poor daker montgomery has been
through some of the most horrific
prosthetics experiences he's basically
fine but he has spent his fair share of
time in the makeup chair and season 4 is
no different and we're not gonna lie
having your stomach completely wrapped
in prosthetics with red goo dripping
down you just does not sound like a fun
time number four that feel when you
quite literally work your butt off and
they demand you put it back on david
harbour is no stranger to extreme
fluctuations in wait for roles and
stranger things brought in the starving
prisoner hopper so when it came to
flashback scenes harbor could not escape
the weight he burned off and had to
carry it around in the form of
prosthetics but you know what he's proud
of his dad bod number 5. it has to be
seen to be believed in order to save
himself from being murdered by vacna
victor kriel gouged out his own eyes the
gowers team designed the scarred island
prosthetics for the character played by
robert englund having limited access to
your vision is enough to drive anybody
insane number six what do you do when
you can't use a safe word christopher
strand's mouth and eyes were sealed with
prosthetics the crew then drove him to
the set and fastened him to the chair
head of the makeup department amy l
forsythe said he couldn't see he
couldn't speak all he could do was hear
when we were breaking for lunch i was
like you better let him know he's done
for the day before you call lunch
because he might just be sitting there
thinking you're abandoning him not
having access to all of your senses can
cause unwelcomed reactions from actors
discomfort being the least of your
concerns and things like claustrophobia
being high up on the list so the makeup
crew did their best to cater to his
situation forsyth continued you ask them
to be very communicative with you on
their experience so that you can help
make adjustments if need be no one knows
their comfort level like they do since
strand had both his eyes and mouth
covered the makeup team only asked yes
or no questions to gauge if he was
feeling okay
number 7 is this what heaven looks like
because it sure feels a lot like the
upside down wearing white contacts
really limits your vision and so anybody
who entered that trance-like state could
hardly see a thing the whole room became
a milky white color and the costume
department did their best to prepare the
actors for their experience forsythe
said i took a lot of videos of people
putting their contacts in for the first
time to get their reactions and try to
make it a little fun experience for them
number eight did nobody tell gayten that
he should bring sensible clothes camping
while gayton matarazzo is a huge fan of
his costumes from the series season 4
being his favorite so far he can't help
but despise just one outfit he's worn
over the years saying i have to say my
least favorite look had nothing to do
with the design in fact it's one of my
favorites but the camp outfit always
felt really tight and tiny he's
referencing the camp nowhere episode
from season three number nine would you
prefer to be wet or sticky all day
daker's dealing with sunburns when he's
meant to be pale and is pale when he's
meant to have color amy from the hair
department had all that fake tan this
one was a pain for the makeup department
because after he'd burned himself
filming a pool scene he had to film the
shower scenes as the mind flare and kept
slamming his back against the wall which
would take off all the cover-up and that
isn't all he was completely coated in a
layer of sticky lip gloss in order to
main that wet sheen which he thinks is
better than being wet all day number 10.
that feel when you have no idea what
you're doing but you have to do it
anyways it reminds us of math class
daker wore 33 prosthetic wounds for the
post sauna scene and problematically
when millie bobby brown broke her knee
right as the shutdown was lifting all of
his scenes were moved up meaning there
was a rush order on all those
prosthetics the designer had no idea
what she was even working with yet and
just created 50 different random wounds
hoping it would work out they also asked
if they wanted billy to bleed red yes
said the director who changed his mind
in a few shots which ended up being left
to the vfx crew to fix in post
number 11. masking real wounds with fake
ones daker had only so many prosthetics
that he didn't even realize he'd bruised
and cut himself all over the place he
only noticed after he removed them at
the end of the day i was covered head to
toe in cuts and bruises and i took all
the skin off the top of my toes number
12 sure playing a creepy alien zombie
monster is cool in theory the demogorgon
was played by actor mark steger in the
first season of stranger things however
it was so uncomfortable to try and
maneuver around in they replaced the
real actor with cgi the following season
number 13. prosthetics are uncomfortable
under the usual circumstances in season
two when billy beats the snot out of
steve steve was already feeling a little
gooey the guy was pretty sick and to
make matters worse he had to have
menthol blown into his eyes in order to
get the desired look
no don't touch it
his prosthetics included a swollen jaw
lump a cut split lip and a mixture of
cotton and dried blood oh and real snot
apparently number 14 white contacts
black contacts what's next will's black
contacts made his eyes burn and despite
how warm everything looks on screen it
was actually very cold on set and will
was not dressed for the weather number
15. this is a friendly reminder to wash
your face nancy dyer put makeup on to
cover up her acne and that caused more
acne isn't it ironic while not
necessarily painful it would play on her
self-esteem ugh we feel you nancy all
too well
from uncomfortable to irritating to
painful to downright unbearable the
stranger things gang has experienced it
all huh i don't know it's like ad-libbed
or whatever that whole thing is
absolutely
by the way the stars of stranger things
are definitely no strangers to the art
of improv this video is chocked full of
every ad-lib improvised moment and
mishap that were kept in the final cut
of season four
number one we know you're with us when
we say finally this time
it's gonna be different we've been
waiting for joyce and hopper to be
reunited ever since he got taken by the
russian government and clearly so were
winona ryder and david harbor according
to a tweet from the stranger things
writers that kiss was totally unscripted
winona and david added it in the day of
filming though they weren't instructed
to do so it seems like they knew the
fans needed that tender moment of
reconciliation between the two
characters
number two we've got a tear jerker here
in this intense sequence max bravely
entered vecna's mind lair for the second
time but unfortunately she didn't make
it out alive she collapses to the ground
bones broken eyes bleeding and has some
heartbreaking final lines clearly
emotions were running high when lucas
played by caleb mclaughlin improvised
the line where he calls out to his
sister erica for help it gives me chills
it was crazy
number three we're not crying you're
crying in this super emotional scene
eleven finally gets to hear how mike
really feels about her i love you for
exactly who you are
you're my superhero which gives her the
strength to break free from vechna's
grasp and put up a fight one thing you
might not know is that finn wolfhard was
incredibly nervous about that monologue
do this one more emotional do it more
confident we just kind of did it a few
different times he kept running through
the lines over and over in his head
trying to be as off book as he could by
the final take the duffer brothers gave
him permission to add whatever he wanted
to it they're like add whatever you want
and so that like you're my superhero
line i just like added
number four just more comedy gold from
joseph quinn in case you haven't noticed
we're big fans over here harrington
scott
don't you before
he definitely seems to have a knack for
coming up with brilliant in the moment
lines because of a tweet from a curious
fan we found out about this additional
improvised moment did he improvise the
don't you big boy at steve in the camper
van too just asking for a friend at
which the writers responded with a
simple yes do you think there's a chance
eddie could return from the upside down
give us your theories in the comments
number 5 we love a good stranger things
stunt charlie heaton and his co-star
eduardo franco had such a great time
working together eduardo was constantly
making charlie laugh with his random
hilarious unscripted one-liners the
scene where they're hitting golf balls
together on top of a cliff had some
strong comedic moments but one in
particular that was totally improvised
was charlie's dive through the van's
window she was just like has all this
tension so i just decided to run and
jump through the window
number six that really is a funny word
man
charlie and eduardo are truly a comedic
dream team they had such great on-screen
chemistry that during many of their
scenes they were able to improv back and
forth with each other they spent about a
week filming this scene in argyle's van
bouncing lines off one another we got to
play around with this they gave us a lot
of freedom to just riff off each other
number seven get ready to have your
heart strings pulled joseph quinn made
quite the impression as the infamous
eddie munson we particularly love his
brotherly relationship with gayton
matarazzo's character dustin apparently
we weren't the only ones feeling the
love according to the writers of
stranger things the line i love you man
was completely improvised by quinn
gayton's natural response of i love you
too definitely solidified the intense
emotional
ending i love you dad
number eight only in a demo fight if we
try that again we'll never be able to
recreate it this is less of an
improvisation and more of a mistake that
was kept in the final cut
in this major scene the demogorgon takes
on a group of prisoners including our
beloved hopper the duffer brothers
really wanted to do this scene in one
shot but it proved to be too dangerous
luckily though they managed to get
something on film they didn't even know
they needed when the demogorgon throws
that guy and the bar collapses that's
actually a mistake but the duffer
brothers thought the shot looked so cool
and was captured so well that they
decided to keep it the way it was
number nine more like an attempted save
we're all familiar with the big shootout
scene that was done in one shot at the
buyer's house
obviously there are going to be some
great behind-the-scenes stories about it
apparently not only does the cast of
stranger things love a good improvised
moment on camera but off-camera is just
as hilarious oh my god dude we just did
all that for nothing like your favorite
memory no no it's coming there's a
moment at the very end of the sequence
where they're about to finish the take
they just need the last soldier to step
inside the house and get shot but during
this take he never makes it in everyone
is pretty annoyed that they have to run
the sequence again but the stuntman
lightens up the mood with a bit of
improv a door gets kicked in and the
stunt guy is like
notably everyone else is standing around
in silent shock and then he got up and
he was like i think that went well
number 10 just some casual heartbreak
before you clock out the scene where
max's bones are breaking as lucas
watches on helplessly was the end of
quite a long day for the young actor he
was instructed to stare up and scream no
but due to the intense emotions of the
scene and overall exhaustion after the
fight with mason dye who plays jason he
stares up and yells max instead but then
when you see it all come together it's
like oh it was worth it in an interview
with we got this covered he talks a
little bit about his experience in that
moment i don't really like to rehearse
scenes like that because i want my
natural reaction i want to be real and
raw in the moment so i went off the cuff
just went for it of course as we did
more takes it got better and felt more
real and it helped that the duffer
brothers allowed me to improv and catch
the energy of the scene
number 11 let's crank that exhaustion up
to 11. we obviously can't forget these
iconic season 3 gems it wouldn't be
right to leave them out one thing we
knew about millie bobby brown is that
she's an insanely hard worker
she always gave 110 during the intense
fight scenes with daker montgomery's
character billy so much so that she
often blew out her voice on the day of
filming the scene where she throws billy
through a brick wall she was so
exhausted by the end that her collapse
into mike's arms was 100 real finn
wolfhard even breaks character for a
moment to look off at the director for
guidance
number 12 oh mike just tell her already
what i want to say is
that
i just a moment we absolutely love from
season three was finn wolfhard's
improvised heart-to-heart scene with
millie bobby brown this moment of
rambling on in the attempt to get to an
i love you was all finn's brilliant
improvisation cbr.com recounts the
moment really well the spontaneity of
wolfhard's lines in this moment can be
noticed when brown tries her best not to
laugh at them ultimately her laughs were
kept in the final cut because her
reaction is true to her character
we get terrified just watching stranger
things especially the fourth season the
actors who had to perform those freaky
scenes had it much worse off and we've
got the scoop on just how brave they had
to be to make these scary moments happen
number one
run max run
yeah it was pretty intense no kidding we
were freaked out just watching it but to
be performing that emotionally
exhausting scene live the fact that they
spent so long doing it definitely didn't
help that was shot over i don't know how
many i think it might have been a week
that we spent on that while the set
wasn't nearly as big as what it looks
like and sadie sink filmed in a smaller
more controlled environment without
details like the vines and such it was
all just enough to freak her out and
while it wasn't fun for her it was great
for the cameras number two
sometimes the scariest creatures are
just below our noses we're talking
bullies that's right as scary as vechna
and the demogorgon creatures of vol 4
are there is still something frightening
about the meanness of a bully and just
how cruel they can be a lot of the
horror comes from the humans in the
story the darkness within all of us
we've seen some real mean-spirited
people in this show and the fact that
people can actually be that hurtful
makes it that much scarier number three
this was a one-shot wonder for real this
should feel
real time and viscerally connected this
one-shot shootout battle made for a
whole lot of planning it was going to be
hard it was going to be near impossible
one intense choreo session that saw the
director playing everyone's parts led to
a scene that would be easy for the
performers to act terrified during i do
believe that the best way to feed my
actors energy is by giving them energy
if we were those actors we would have
been okay with just a bit less energy
number four
the demogorgon is back bigger and badder
than ever would we expect anything less
from this team let's let this thing
loose and see what it can do and that
they did the sequence was so intense to
shoot they actually had to break it down
into three different parts meaning the
torture went on much longer than the
performers would have liked the stunt
team that performed this wild sequence
are trained professionals and have done
freaky stunts before but this scene was
next level swinging upside down wildly
definitely wouldn't be top of our list
either
number five this is the stuff that
nightmares are made of not like that my
goal is to make children not be able to
sleep that's what he says but the show
well it seems to indicate otherwise it's
gonna be very exciting very scary we've
seen flash dear monsters before but with
vecna and we wanted something that was
much more sentient when millie bobby
brown first came face to face with jamie
campbell bauer and all his makeup the
actress was totally shook so terrified
that she just burst into tears and
sobbed uncontrollably we can't imagine
who wouldn't be freaked out by vechna
now we have an emotionally invested
motivated and revenge desiring character
number six
this wasn't a casual swim yeah seeing
steve dive so deep is freaky but what's
even more terrifying is the fact that it
was the actor himself performing that
stunt the place of his nightmares was
the giant water tank it was in a big
convention center in atlanta luckily joe
kiri had been prepping and had
anticipated swimming for the show in the
first season and in the script they're
like yeah you're gonna be a swimmer and
while it took four seasons to literally
dive in kiri's prep helped him for sure
but it didn't take away all the nerves
of filming such an intense sequence
underwater getting to do that sort of
stuff is like true movie magic number
seven it got real cold poor david harbor
went through the ringer filming hopper's
escape in russia since he had to immerse
himself right into the tough stuff for a
lot of it i'm running shoeless and it's
really not pleasant the physical aspect
was not fun at all but what really shook
the actor was how much it affected his
psyche it was brutal like uh physically
in that way and it was also kind of
brutal emotionally we've got a feeling
he wouldn't want to go through that
again number eight the darkest season so
far that is season four has not
disappointed season four it was let's go
nightmare in elm street let's go
hellraiser and now that the actors were
a bit older they weren't worried about
pushing them as much so things got
intense for the first time for them it's
like it's really we wanted to be really
scary so what better way to get those
terrified reactions than by actually
terrifying the cast let's just push this
and try to be as scary as possible and
put them in the middle of a true horror
film balancing the comedy with the
horror was key for this season making
the big clashes and vibes even more
evident it felt like right to go darker
number nine
she spun and she spun and then well she
nearly puked when it came time to film
the sequence that sees eleven falling
into billy's memories the actress had no
choice but to perform the freaky stunt
leaving her totally nauseous and gagging
physically it was exhausting and feeling
all that while filming content that's
supposed to be intense well we can
understand if she had some trouble
sleeping afterwards number 10.
baths are supposed to be relaxing but
not in this show can anyone blame
francesca real for being horrified while
filming this scene well the pool was
scary for a few reasons the actress
shared that i hate any body of water
that has a black bottom and this pool
you guessed it had a black bottom but
she wasn't alone in the pool no no real
shared they had this amazing mechanism
that attached to my foot and whenever i
was ready i would go down underwater and
the mechanism would tug me down
yeah we are not so sure we'd call that
mechanism amazing more like something
that could potentially drown you
number eleven
nothing about this sounds fun we're
throwing back to season two and the
attempts to get rid of the monster
attached to will and to say was
traumatic is putting it lightly schnapp
tried to remain professional throughout
the process but the struggle was real he
explained there were so many angles and
shots that they had to do for each shot
like you have to give it your all so
every angle every different shot it was
just constantly screaming okay so we can
conclude the experience of filming this
scene was equal parts terrifying and
exhausting number 12
say it ain't so
the reaction will byers mom was having
on the show dealing with the loss of
will was pretty close to what noah
schnapp's actual mom experienced when
the duffer brothers played quite the
cruel and dark joke on her the
prosthetic will body that's used as a
fake in the first season was
terrifyingly realistic so we can
understand why schnapp's actual mom was
shook when she first saw it fortunately
she found the joy in it soon enough and
wound up taking photos with the dummy
number 13.
being trapped underwater is usually
terrifying the nerves we feel just
thinking of all of eleven's time spent
in the tank facing terrifying images
every time are real so we can only begin
to imagine the kind of nightmares milly
was having since she was actually
filming underwater with only a sea trek
helmet in place that allowed her to
breathe if she weren't afraid of
drowning before we wouldn't be surprised
if she was after this number 14.
if you know
you know
i'm terrified
demogorgons are terrifying we know that
for sure but for toddlers that were
hanging around on set for the first
season well they were fully unsettled
even millie was freaking out on the
inside i'm frightened about everything
since they did have to get through
filming one of the grown-ups sunset
tried to help the actors through it by
telling them it was the same monster
they knew from monsters inc a surprising
comparison but it worked for the kids
number 15.
they didn't know what hit them these
young actors faced their fears time and
time again in the early years but for
season four to truly frighten them well
it's not something they anticipated
definitely exceeded my expectations with
how scary they could go but just how
scary would they say it is
oh definitely an 11. yeah we'll stay on
this side of the screen
do you ever wonder what's really going
on in the actors minds as they film
intense scenes in vecna's mind layer or
play metallica on guitar while a horde
of killer bats approach yeah stick
around we got you
number one get ready for a whole new
meaning of death metal joseph quinn goes
through so much when playing the
infamous eddie but for an afternoon in
season 4 he gets to have quite a bit of
fun as a rock star prior to reading the
script joseph received a text from the
duffer brothers asking if he could play
guitar they kind of texted me during the
hiatus being like you play guitar i said
yes
question mark nothing he had no idea
what they had in store until much later
his reaction after reading the script
then i was just are you kidding was much
different after seeing the sequence play
out it feels earned and it feels fun and
it feels like the perfect crescendo for
this crazy sequence number two get that
kleenex ready this is a super emotional
scene for joseph quinn and for everyone
to watch quinn thinks it's a delicate
way of giving eddie some well-deserved
justice the pill that people are kind of
finding hard to swallow is that people
don't know that he dies a hero of course
though would we rather have our guy
eddie alive and well it's very
touching but it's still not right number
three we're jumping in right along with
you steve joe kiri for the first time
gets to show off all of the swim
training he did for the show like i was
paying for all this stuff and then we i
showed up and they're like oh no yeah we
cut that we couldn't get a pool in this
scene joe gets to plunge into a 40-foot
tank built entirely for this moment
getting to do that sort of stuff is like
true
movie magic number four sadie sink
barely made it out of this one her
performance is nothing short of
incredible but what was it like from her
perspective
um a lot of time spent in the harness i
guess she really got to have the full
experience on this set because most of
the pieces were created by the art
department like this is the most
elaborate form of harness harnessing
that i've ever done
we also can't forget how creepy vecna
was his look is almost fully practical
which kind of
made it easier for me so i'm not like
staring at a man in a green suit number
five stancey anyone we haven't gotten to
see steve and nancy together in quite a
while so it was really exciting to see
their dynamic after all the characters
growth they've undergone
not only that but joe kiri was also
pumped to work with natalya dyer again
it's fun to like work together again
actually because we haven't really
worked together in a long time though
they couldn't give us any information
regarding the future of their
relationship natalia did make it clear
that the show wants to portray two
people who truly care about each other
number six we take a visit to the
country club for this one
the scene where jonathan and argyle are
shooting golf balls into an abandoned
junkyard was one of charlie heaton's
favorite scenes to shoot in season 4. he
and eduardo actually had to take golfing
lessons beforehand a costume like gave
us these very yuppy golfy golfing
outfits to go turn up to this country
club in they were surprised by how
difficult just hitting a golf ball could
really be so yeah we had a lot of
practice trying to hit these balls which
were ridiculously hard eduardo was also
constantly making charlie laugh and
throwing out brilliant one-liners that
weren't in the script because of their
natural chemistry they ended up creating
some hilarious moments when charlie runs
and jumps through the window of the van
that wasn't actually in the script me
and eduardo were building each other up
so much it was like that was always
tension sir i just decided to run and
jump through the window number seven is
this stranger things or scooby-doo okay
there's a scooby-doo show oh yeah this
scene though it looks super cool and
high-end was actually filmed inside a
warehouse in true stranger things
fashion everything you see was built
completely by the art department gayton
joe and maya loved filming there i have
a great great memories about shooting
this yeah this is like a really funny
and not so different from his character
steve joe kiri gets to save a few lives
in between takes remember when you saved
my life maya hawk almost took an
unfortunate tumble off the edge of the
set there was like gaps in the thing
yeah the laser was supposed to be
off of it and joe in true steve
harrington fashion immediately grabbed
her and pulled her back up number eight
a hospital visit might be necessary
after this one this intense scene was
shot over the course of two days about
14 hours of filming
that moment where charlie heaton slams a
voz into tom's face needed some
extensive rehearsal
had to rehearse that so many times
safely yeah to get the choreography
michael park who plays tom was a great
sport about it though one time you
really got it i know really he said if
you hit him harder it's gonna hurt less
michael was willing to take as many hits
as he needed for the sake of the scene
at one point his entire ear was red from
being slammed so hard
due to the number of breaks they had to
take to set up for different angles they
had to sort of psych themselves up to be
in that intense heightened state that
the scene requires that also feels
really nice to come home from a day's
work and feel like you put your body
through like the ring number nine we've
all got one david harbor isn't shy about
the way he feels working with the kids
of stranger things or feel like an angry
uncle i guess like just a grumpy annoyed
neighbor though he may not feel like a
parent on set he did find his protective
side coming out because of that he says
that he was much harder on them than
others might have been on a serious tip
i mean i am very protective of those
kids number 10. who knew playing a board
game could be so nerve-wracking it'd be
impossible for finn wolfhard and caleb
mclaughlin to forget shooting this scene
mostly because it was the very first one
they ever did both of them were insanely
nervous the day of caleb even got sick
because of it we were all i think just
really like just scared because we had
no idea like you know we didn't have any
rehearsal or anything luckily though
nerves definitely became a lot calmer so
common fact that the guys couldn't stop
laughing it took us a while to get that
scene done but it was so much fun number
eleven hue up a never-ending story
yeah that was also just such a weird
scene it was although we're always down
to hear sadie sings incredible vocal
skills she thought the scene was a bit
odd because of all the heartache that
happened earlier in the episode max's
brother just died and then i saw that in
the script i was like what's going on
now we're just like singing and dancing
regardless she was happy to have a
lighthearted moment to balance out all
the heavy emotions number 12 we're still
not over it this is a bittersweet scene
for the cast a great day on set for finn
wolfhard is getting to do scenes with
the entire cast usually in those big
group scenes we're all just really happy
because we all get to just like do a
scene together and hang out but in this
case happiness was definitely not the
prime emotion i was pretty emotional
that day that was one of the final
scenes that were shot for season three
so in a way we're actually getting to
watch authentic goodbyes among the cast
in a way you're actually saying bye yeah
and you can and it was like felt natural
to hug everyone yeah there are so many
incredible stories and emotions hidden
behind the stranger things moments
sometimes you forget how hard the actors
have to work to give them to us can you
please not touch anything part of the
fun of working on a set is finding what
you can take home afterwards while it's
not always the best practice the
stranger things actors have done their
fair share of swiping from the set
keeping special props and costume pieces
from the show with the hope that they
won't get caught which actors stole the
most items from set let's do some
investigating i've thought about
stealing things and never have i'm a
good boy
oh my god see number one who wants to go
for a roll thanks to his sticky fingers
noah schnapp can go roller skating
anytime he wants with his very own pair
of 80s style stranger things roller
skates i'm so bad at this i'm like bambi
on ice
you're good but he wasn't shy about
taking them the actor explained i
brought the roller skates home i had
everyone sign them and then took them
home with me okay we've gotta be honest
that's an epic set steal and if we had a
chance at getting a signed pair of
roller skates from this cast well we'd
be all over it number two
millie had a bloody good time on the set
of stranger things my blood
that i put in my nose for real though
how many times do we think she had to
perform nosebleeds on the set if blood
made her squeamish before she'd
certainly faced her fears and gotten
real comfortable with it so comfortable
that she wanted to make sure she had
some with her even when she wasn't on
set that seems to be the only logical
reason as to why millie would have
stolen a small vial of eleven's fake
blood to keep in her memento box this is
one she'll never forget that's for sure
and we hope she doesn't forget that she
stole it otherwise that discovery could
be a bit freaky i have a memory book so
i keep all my lipsticks from every award
show i went to my envelope from the mtv
awards and then the blood from stranger
things number three
keeping cozy is worth stealing for sadie
sync has been pretty good about not
taking too many things from set but she
just couldn't leave without bringing
something with her it wasn't like a
costume was just like a warming jacket
from
wardrobe it has like it's just the
jacket she even caught noah by surprise
and while it is suspect sync has
explained that this wasn't a purposeful
swipe but not everyone seems totally
convinced again accidentally no but like
accidentally number four it would have
been pretty easy to leave the set with
these costume pieces we have no doubt
noah schnapp makes a decent paycheck
doing stranger things so we are a bit
confused that he felt compelled to steal
this particular costume piece i took a
bunch of underwear but that's really it
they must have been comfy no doubt we
wonder if anyone from set noticed he'd
become an underwear thief number five
shoplifting ain't cool millie
but does it really count if it's a fake
mall on stranger things i took she went
full tilt in the star court mall having
a full-on shopping spree on set without
any money involved of course it was
definitely a set store but i did take
um like corduroy jeans and a stripy red
and blue t-shirt and while it might have
been a fake gap store the clothes were
real and they looked good no wonder she
kept that stuff for herself
number six
it seems like millie was a bit desperate
what other explanation could there be
for her stealing such a small and random
item from the set or maybe she was just
trying to be like noah i took a lot of
socks any guesses on whether or not noah
stole more underwear or millie stole
more socks let's do it let's do it we'll
never know but we can imagine the
wardrobe department wasn't too impressed
with having to replace all those stolen
necessities
number seven
we've got our eyes on you caleb when it
came time to talk about what he swiped
from set during an interview caleb
mclachlan was pretty strategic about it
luckily he saved himself from letting
any spoilers slip but he also outed
himself pretty obviously we know he
stole something but whatever it was
continues to remain a mystery
accidentally i took uh like something
from set from season three we wonder if
he ever got caught number eight he looks
pretty suspicious
is it just us or does noah look like he
got caught in the hot seat we move on
right never took it okay so we've
established there is an it that he stole
but what could it be since sadie sink
gave the actor a look indicating it's
not something noah should probably talk
about it seems like his lips are sealed
we won't push it but we just can't help
but wonder what memento he snuck off set
with and we doubt he's talking about the
underwear in this case
number nine for real real though
i did a show called intruders um when i
was nine years old she may have been
young but even early on millie knew that
you've got to take advantage of being on
set by keeping any cool things you can i
took a lighter from the set it was a
prop being used on set but of all things
why did she need it what did she plan to
do with it this special lighter from
intruders wound up going into her
memento box with souvenirs from other
productions that lighter could always
help her find her light that's for sure
number 10 finn wolfhard might have some
answers on this one when he was filming
ghostbusters there were plenty of
opportunities to snag all the
ghost-busting materials but that wasn't
what appealed to the actor i kept some
shoes that i wore
on the new ghostbusters movie hey if the
shoes were good enough for ghost busting
then why not stick to him while he did
swipe the shoes generally wolfhard is
pretty good and hasn't actually stolen
much from set when asked if he'd taken
anything from the stranger things set he
very openly shared that he's never
stolen anything from that set in
particular for fear that the production
team would end up needing whatever he
stole at some point and then he'd be
found out that said he has confessed to
wishing he stole the ritchie glasses
from the movie it there's stuff that i
regret that i didn't keep like i wish i
kept the ritchie glasses and who knows
there is hope that maybe he'll get them
in future you never know maybe i could
get those back number 11
when you know
you know any fans of enola homes will
know that millie formed a very special
bond on set with one of her well her
dash i took dash which you will see this
set swipe definitely makes sense and she
was the title character so we guess
millie had some leeway in terms of what
she could keep from set for herself
extraordinary
while she did swipe it she had said
before that it was a gift but no one has
confirmed that fact either what we do
know is that dash isn't the only thing
millie kept from the anola home sect
number 12.
millie's got the tools and a corset i
must become something
unexpected the stranger things actress
has spent plenty of time in a harness
doing stunts for the sci-fi show but
ninola holmes she was dealing with a
very different kind of restriction and
instead of being glad about saying
farewell to a typically uncomfortable
and annoying costume piece millie wanted
to keep her corset for herself
[Music]
maybe she wanted to remind herself of
the struggle she injured while filming
or it could just be that she loved
getting her posture in check and that
corset will certainly do the trick being
so young these movies and shows are a
pretty formative part of the stranger
things actors lives so it makes sense
they'd want to keep these mementos from
their various projects whether they were
kept for practical reasons or just the
memories everyone seems pretty cool with
the practice of swiping some stuff from
set even if it does have to be kept a
secret for a while to make sure no one
gets in trouble stranger things is
a pretty nasty show containing a ton of
gooey prosthetics and farty boys that
are smelly enough to evacuate a bus
several times over ready to find out who
the worst offender was number one we're
kicking it off with something sticky
actually pretty much everything in this
list consists of sticky things that
would have been a good alternate title
for the show putting on gross nasty
prosthetics and seeing yourself in the
mirror is one thing taking off gross
nasty prosthetics is a much stranger
thing but we've got to admit playing
around with prosthetic goo does look
pretty satisfying
slimy yet satisfying as simba would say
number two beards are gross in general
go clean shaven boys kidding a nice
beard can do wonders for the jawline in
the case of david harbour he had way
more than just a beard and it did the
opposite for his jaw he had to get
suited up in a prosthetic that reflected
the weight he was in season three for
the flashback scene so that means that
that neck isn't real that's a fake beard
with fake beard hair oh boy that's a
little strange downright uncomfy harbor
can't stand prosthetics but the process
for this one was pretty painless thanks
to an awesome team
number three oh dear what direction
could we possibly go with this turns out
that lube has more than one purpose it's
great for maneuvering in prosthetics
jamie campbell bower had the honor of
slicking up for vechna the product isn't
just great for prosthetics though did
you know your friendly neighborhood
spiderman had to use lube to get into
his spidey suit and no way home or at
least tom holland did at any rate oh to
spend an entire day slimy just sounds
like a nightmare
number four and now for the most
disgusting thing on this whole list
kissing matt duffer acknowledged that it
was easy to forget how young milly was
sometimes because she's so incredibly
gifted for her age
well her age would shine through
sometimes of course like when it came to
kissing finn wolfhard in season one
there was a two-month build-up to that
scene for millie about just how
disgusting and horrible it was going to
be and she questioned the whole time why
the duffers wrote it in that definitely
reminded them that she was only 11 years
old not the character well that too she
survived though number five lego myego
i'm gonna be sick after being spun
around and around and around in one
scene in the void poor milly lost her
eggos we can't say we blame her that
looks intense
in a post she captioned it you spin me
right round baby right round ah
threw up after this this isn't the first
time millie's thrown up on set either at
least so the duffer brothers thought she
was pretty bold in season one to prank
the creators then we pretended that i
was really sick and we put water in my
mouth and then she started puking up the
water classic
number six a glossy finish that still
manages to look just
terrible daker was covered head to toe
in lip gloss to achieve that flayed look
not just lip gloss though also dirt
and mud not just lip gloss dirt and mud
but also an extra layer of lip gloss to
seal it all together
sounds like a party number 7. millie's
nosebleeds are pretty wild so before the
scene starts she has to pour the fake
blood up her nose they immediately start
filming and basically hope for the best
as far as timing goes fun fact that's
the reason she tips her head down when
she's using her powers to get the goo
moving there are two kinds of fake blood
well probably a lot more but two
different categories of fake blood
there's the kind you wear and the kind
that goes inside your body for millie's
nosebleeds she was using corn syrup
number eight we're not done with the
internal goo yet though the edible blood
that is usually consumed via the mouth
and not the nose has to be made safe for
the actor and well one thing you don't
have to worry about when it comes to
noses is taste but the mouth is a whole
other story the edible blood tastes
pretty freaking disgusting but as
stranger things progressed their
concoctions got a little tastier it's
just an added gesture from the makeup
team to make the fake blood taste better
among the options for flavor are
emergency and jello number nine while
this might seem like a delectable treat
to most noah schnapp was having none of
it along the lines of the bloods there's
sometimes a need for discoloration and
head of makeup amy forsythe wanted will
buyers to look ill so they faded out the
color on his tongue you'd think green
food coloring and frosting wouldn't be
such a bad combination but turns out
schnapp hates frosting hey you can't
please everyone for all the torture
forsyth put will through with frosting
he was given permission to enact his
revenge and got to spray amy with a
super soaker
number 10 caffeine is always the answer
david harbour is coated in mud sorry not
mud sticky espresso grounds that the
makeup team stole right from the
espresso maker in the trailer and the
recipe had to be exact no substitutions
coffee just isn't good enough it has to
be espresso and popper was covered in
mud a lot in season two while harbor was
a good sport about it amy said he was
happy for the hot towel at the end of
the day
number 11. sometimes it isn't the gross
prosthetics sometimes it's the actors
themselves being gross filming in a bus
isn't normally a sign of alarm unless
one of the boys is so gassy the bus has
to be evacuated more than once poor
millie was furious with her stinky
co-star it's never been revealed who cut
the cheddar which is very kind of them
to keep it under wraps we guess but this
wasn't an isolated event david harbour
admitted they would sometimes fart
during takes yep
kids little human beings with big
important jobs farting during cakes i
won't say which one
number 12. eating cold burgers and fries
is definitely not as satisfying as
eating cold pineapple pizza yes way back
in season one millie was eating cold
burgers and fries a lot of cold burgers
and fries like a lot a lot like too much
for an adult male to stomach let alone a
10 year old girl
we mean like at least three burgers in a
single sitting poor milly they always
encourage actors to eat healthy and then
they do this to them
number 13. that feel when they get you
when you're down poor joe kiri had to
film while sick this was more common
before the days of the dreaded pandemic
he was super stuffed up to begin with
but then to get the redness in his eyes
they blew menthol into them ouch he was
already a gooey snotty mess before the
staged beating came into it he also had
to have prosthetics applied to his face
he had a swollen jaw lump a cut split
lip and a mix of cotton and dried blood
here's hoping the appendages were sneeze
resistant number 14. eggos are actually
just the worst when you eat them
straight out of the box we recommend a
flamethrower whenever you see actors
eating food in a movie just know they
were in for a miserable few hours
because one eggo on screen is like two
dozen in front of the camera we bet
millie will never look at eggos the same
way again number 15. was this one more
disgusting for the actors or for us
definitely us the leg you're looking at
isn't even millies in this scene it was
totally just prosthetics all decked out
with different layers of yuck luckily
the moving mind flare was added in
post-production and wasn't some creepy
animatronic below the surface honestly
we couldn't stomach if it were any more
real than it already is
while the disgusting blob of rat bodies
that merged to become a monster would
have made a great addition to this list
if you haven't already figured it out
only the animators were tortured with
that job when you're in the upside down
things can get kind of crazy so you know
there were embarrassing moments on the
stranger things set who unintentionally
interrupted scenes which actor was the
best jokester but before we dive in you
should probably subscribe to our new
channel the things animated to get all
the hidden secrets and unique theories
behind your favorite animated movies and
shows
number one sometimes you get what's
coming to you noah schnapp didn't know
what hit him but it was a long time
coming since while he's the biggest
prankster of them all schnapp wound up
embarrassing plenty of co-stars through
practical jokes so while filming season
four it was time he got a taste of his
own medicine let's set the scene so it
was 4 am we were in new mexico schnapp
was busy filming while millie bobby
brown and the team got to work we had
trash bins
filled with water balloons all around
and we turned all the lights off at base
camp brown lured noah over with her
excellent acting skills no i'm just so
upset that you know you're not you're
not here to say goodbye to me please
just come back to base camp i'm leaving
now when his best friend needs him he'll
be there but instead of finding a
teary-eyed millie he got a whole crew
taking revenge on him and i get him in
the middle of the car park all of us
about 20 people raid him this cast does
not mess around with her practical jokes
number two
their lips were sealed and i'm not gonna
name names
because it's pretty embarrassing in the
early days filming on the bus got a bit
stuffy and one person was left feeling
real embarrassed
somebody farted on the bus we were
filming in and we had to clear out for
about 20 minutes but that's not the
worst of it there wound up being two
performers trying to avoid being called
out and then we got back on after like
20 minutes of airing this thing out and
somebody else farted it was a smelly
mystery that's for sure they tried to
blame it on the initial perpetrator that
said filming that day happened to be one
of gaiden matarazzo's absolute favorites
we wonder if he's keeping any secrets we
still don't know where that second part
looks
number three
this one ended in tears yikes noah
schnab and millie bobby brown wound up
being the ones embarrassed after playing
this joke on one of the crew members
that went a bit too far the actors were
bored on set one day and decided to give
the crew member a ring pretending to be
the manager of the venue where their
wedding was meant to take place just two
weeks later they thought it would be
funny to tell her that they had to
cancel lorezzo because of construction
but they were mortified when that crew
member wound up bursting into tears
instead you can bet the two were
blushing all day after that joke gone
wrong
number four
he's coming in there were like 200
people in the room just stabbed
finn wolfhard went ahead and made his
very first kiss with millie bobby brown
on screen super awkward
coming in looking back finn isn't so
crazy about the scene it looks like i
was eating her like i was like ah was he
hoping milly would feel better about the
kiss that way
luckily that day was probably the worst
of it and it became a less embarrassing
process as they went on i will say this
it's we've we've progressed number five
the accents can be tricky charlie heaton
is always professional and his american
accent is on point but funnily enough he
has a whole lot of trouble with one name
and it's one he really should be able to
say they've dated on and off screen so
the fact that heaton really struggles to
say the name nancy properly leaves him
blushing constantly on set to make
matters worse he actually had to come in
for separate recording sessions to
re-record any time he said nancy so it
sounded right in the final edit
number six
this is never not awkward but it's
especially bad when it happens to be
your first kiss in real life too i mean
i guess technically would be the one
that was in stranger things to make it
all worse caleb mclaughlin and sadie
sink were not expecting it
there wasn't a word about this happening
in the script or talks beforehand but
the day of the actors were put on the
spot and the pressure was on it's a lot
of kids just like ooh you're gonna kiss
her
poor sadie sank also had to deal with
the fact that her mom happened to be
there to witness it all has there ever
been a more embarrassing first kiss
scenario
in front of like so many people yeah
that was that was it
number seven
clothing in the 80s was different finn
wolfhard had a real hard time when he
was handed a classic pair of tidy
whities a la 80s for him to wear in case
his underwear was showing from under his
pants on the show the actor was so
embarrassed at the thought he didn't
even give them a chance insisting to his
co-stars
i'm not wearing these i'm just gonna
wear my real things my real underwear
number eight
you do what you gotta do that's the
motto that caleb mclaughlin has learned
to roll with being part of the stranger
things cast he was very excited to film
the scene early on that saw him sneaking
up on his pal but then this happens
that part wasn't so fun but he was
always a professional about it despite
his feelings as an actor you do it you
do it you do it you love the art you do
it and that's why i did it number nine
it's a look
playing a kid in the 80s isn't all it's
cracked up to be especially in the hair
department season three was this huge
wig and season four it was these little
extensions and noah schnapp never knew
what he was going to get from the wig
team what he could guarantee was the
fact that he'd be real embarrassed to be
wearing those wigs on set no matter what
he was given
number 10
no one wants to call attention to
themselves this way
remember the smelly situation that
happened on the bus well it happened
again in the series but instead of
distracting everyone with the stench it
was a fully audible situation caleb
mclaughlin was the guilty one in this
case and it was much harder to get out
of since the whole set was pretty quiet
and gade monorazzo had been right next
to him meaning he heard everything
matarazzo struggled to keep his cool
explaining we were dying but we couldn't
laugh out loud because they were doing a
really dramatic scene in there talk
about awkward timing
number eleven
caleb mclaughlin is even more talented
than we thought when it comes to
multitasking this actor is king always a
jokester on set he decided to see what
would happen if during the middle of a
take he blew his nose while eating an
apple at the same time don't ask us why
he did it it seems like he was just
moved to spice things up no one
understood what he was doing and he did
make a bit of a fool of himself but it
worked out well since on camera it was
pretty hilarious
number 12
maintaining composure is tougher than
you'd think it was
it was four like 12 year olds all
together drinking coca-cola and eating
old pizza yeah that just sounds like a
recipe for disaster for
six hours filming playing games together
was a pretty childlike vibe and the team
did encourage a chilled environment so
they could get the very best out of the
kids but it was still pretty high strung
who can blame them though it was the
very early days what better day to have
the giggles in your first day at work
for the first scene of the first season
number 13. what's in a name really well
in this one there's a whole lot we know
him as caleb mclaughlin but on set he's
known as chocolate daddy okay at least
that's what he refers to himself as on
set and while it's cool in the moment
the actor wasn't so crazy about the
world knowing after he let the secret
slip during an interview
number 14
to be late is to be fired yikes lily
bobby brown has regularly proven she's
an absolute professional in the business
but she didn't leave such a great
impression when she showed up to the set
for filming stranger things a full hour
late and since she's one of the stars it
didn't affect just her the whole
production schedule was thrown off we
can't imagine she was too proud of that
one
number fifteen
you never know which word will throw you
off for david harbour it was
it's your grandma
the actor usually oh so calm cool and
collected was the embarrassment of the
day as he turned out blooper after
blooper after blooper unable to get
through the scene without breaking
character with this crew it was hard not
to laugh
hurt
is good it means you're out of that cave
today we're checking out all the painful
scenes the stranger things cast had to
film from vomiting to slingshots in the
face this young cast was put through the
ringer it's been an experience of a
lifetime number one millie bobby brown
had a serious case of fomo millie found
season four to be the hardest one yet
for filming because she had such a dark
plot in contrast to her co-stars and
found she was separated from them a lot
it's a harder script it's a harder
storyline while that is pretty normal
for stranger things she could see flynn
and some of the others having fun on set
getting to do the more lighthearted
comedic work and she just didn't get to
be a part of it and when you grow up
with your co-stars and they're your best
friends that's rough milly said you get
to see 11 in the darkest state she's
ever been this has definitely been the
hardest season i've ever filmed there
have been some of the scariest scariest
things that i've ever seen as a human
number two well it wasn't its intended
purpose but it works to shoot the scenes
where steve is beat up joe kiri was
already feeling sick and had to have
menthol blown into his eyes to achieve
the desired redness which is fun to look
at and probably less fun to be
vienna listen vic's vaporub contains
menthol and what is vixx for a stuffy
nose so we're pretty sure that's the
excuse they went with when joe
accidentally put it in his eye hey if it
was intentional maybe it helped clear
his sinuses number three joe wasn't the
only one vomiting the a pluribus unum
episode had 11 in the void struggling to
break free from billy's grasp well as
she fell away she twirled around for
this stunt milly was attached to a rig
that spun her in circles millie admitted
physically it was so unbelievably
challenging for me are you okay
okay after a few takes it's no surprise
that this made millie throw up
afterwards she posted about it with the
caption you spin me right round baby
right round threw up after this number
four millie was really spinning before
but now it's just her head that's
spinning shooting inside the sauna was
tough on the whole cast and crew i think
i just threw up in my mouth but it seems
millie took the most of the heat they
spent four full days on a tiny stage
practically the size of a real sauna
with six actors and about a hundred crew
it was squishy and it was super hot and
they shot the scene a million different
ways the scene gone wrong is the scene
that made it into the show when she
collapsed into finn wolfhard's arms that
was due to real exhaustion you can even
see mike break character slightly as he
looks over for help number five millie
might find it too warm but we're gonna
stick around it's quite nice in this
sauna taker montgomery went a little bit
too extreme and smashed his head against
the sauna's glass
you think this
is funny the headbutt was totally
improvised and sadly didn't make it into
the final shot number six let's just say
there's a reason schools don't allow
kids to have slingshots slingshots are
not toys they are weapons meant for
taking out the creepy upside-down
monsters and that's it well caleb
mclaughlin clearly didn't get the memo
and hit himself in the face instead no
ah
number seven we imagine millie was
feeling that fomo around this time too
millie bobby brown split open her
kneecap before filming stranger things
season three so she couldn't do many
stunts or even too much strenuous
movement which included riding a bike
and as we know the cast happens to do
that a lot number eight the prosthetics
king daker had to wear 33 prosthetics
for a time and you know what that means
so did his stunt double that's a lot of
prosthetics at one point it was so hot
and sticky out that daker got himself
stuck to the tablecloth while he was on
lunch and because of millie's knee
injury daker's scenes got moved up which
put a lot of pressure on the makeup crew
to get the prosthetics designed
efficiently sacrifices had to be made
time over quality we had great fun
because i would spend like two hours
every day
getting hair makeup done and the
prosthetics had such an impact on him
that he realized his body hair wasn't
growing back in certain patches but that
isn't all that was underneath the
prosthetics daker didn't realize he'd
been roughed up as bad as he had been
until he took off all his fake injuries
to reveal real ones underneath daker
admitted i was covered head to toe in
cuts and bruises and i took all the skin
off the top of my toes i just kind of
invest in it number nine while schnapp
may have looked sweaty the only thing
that was burning was his eyes noah
schnapp's black contacts seriously made
his eyes fiery but that wasn't the only
thing that made filming his possession
scene tough it was winter in real life
and his costume was not good for the
weather and the heaters you can see in
the show weren't generating any real
heat ugh what a tease number 10. why
couldn't she have just landed a comedy
or even a simple drama would do the best
way to ruin your acting career is to
obliterate your vocal cords millie had
to scream so much on stranger things
that she lost her voice five times in
eight months but she also had to go back
in for adr and so lost it all over again
we wonder if this halted production or
if they knew these screams would need
healing time and worked the schedule
around them number 11. poor demogorgons
deep down they're just a guy in a
seriously uncomfortable situation the
demogorgon prosthetic outfit was tough
for mark seeger to navigate he had to do
some really difficult stunts in it but
what made it so problematic was his
sight was super restricted too it was so
tough to pull off that eventually they
decided to go with cgi instead it had to
do things a practical guy in a suit just
can't do
number 12. noah more screaming or your
vocal cords might snap we'll see
ourselves out millie wasn't the only one
destroying her vocal cords during one
long night shoot noah had to scream with
everything he had until 6am for the
exercising scene because of course
stranger things likes to get a million
different tangles number 13. we would
rather face a demogorgon than get in a
cold pool millie bobby brown was
submerged in freezing cold water for the
suspension scene despite the crew's best
efforts to keep the water warm it was
just too shallow and got cold too quick
number 14. we never really thought of
filming like groundhog day before but it
really is in some regards joe kiri found
the breakup scene he had to shoot with
natalya to be overwhelming as he hadn't
quite perfected the process of letting
go of his character once the camera
stopped rolling to be broken up with
again and again and again was incredibly
tough for him number 15. don't cry if
you cry then i'm gonna cry and if we're
all crying who's gonna comfort us in
that incredibly emotional goodbye scene
in which the whole cast of kids needed
to somehow manage to bring themselves to
tears they found they didn't need to
rely on sad music or menthol in the eyes
just the thought of actually saying
goodbye one day was enough to do it a
reality that is coming too quickly if
you ask us millie mentioned that one of
the cast of kids proposed imagine if we
had to do this for real one day what if
when stranger things is over we'll all
have to say goodbye to each other and
like this is it and then everyone
started crying and they got the shot the
only thing more painful than any of
these moments will be coming up at the
end of season five the end we're not
ready to think about that yet
distraction technique do you think
millie bobby brown is going to method
with her acting or do you think her
level of intensity is necessary for her
performance to come across as genuine
certainly one of the biggest netflix
shows of all time had its ups and downs
for the cast and for the stars of
stranger things they may have had more
downs than one expects we got an inside
look into some of the most painful and
terrifying scenes cast members were a
part of and we'll explain why they're
not their most favorite ones too
number one a whole lot of action for
nothing yeah that's not what this cast
is about apparently while filming a
lengthy shootout scene in season 4 finn
wolfhard had a very frustrating
experience he won't give us much about
the scene but we do know the group is
caught up in some sort of shootout with
a bunch of men in body armor the
director explained to them beforehand
that they would need to shoot this
complex bit in one go so every moving
part needed to hit their marks but
unfortunately the first go was nearly
flawless that is until one of the
soldiers missed their mark we do
everything and then the camera whips to
the door and the soldier is not there
even after this first take wolfhard was
pretty ducked out but they had to just
keep pushing through till everything
came out perfectly
number two talk about a strange reaction
nobody ever knew where caleb mclaughlin
would take lucas sinclair in stranger
things and of all the scenes he deemed
uncomfortable he found a moment in
season 4 to take things off the rails
for him as caleb explains he and mason
dye who portrays jason carver have a
little tense showdown rather than stick
to the script all caleb could muster was
as this was the final episode of season
four he couldn't get into it too much
all we really know was that sadie sync
was confused and everybody else was just
laughing
like laughing and it's just it was a
running joke we would never expect lucas
would do anything less bizarre this
embarrassing moment stuck with
mclaughlin till the end of the shoot
which doesn't make this his most
favorite scene to shoot so every time we
had to do that scene oh man number three
we've all come to like steve a little
bit more especially after season one but
whether he was redeemed or not we were a
little happy he got some payback with
being tied up oh that was actually
pretty brutal to be honest being tied
together that was really tough however
we're not happy that the awesome joe
kiri looked back at this scene as one of
his least favorites as steve is taken by
the russians in season 3 he's dragged
and tied up by the soldiers looked
pretty painful to us and apparently to
joe it was as painful as it looks and
lengthy too he revealed just the scene
of him being tied up and dragged took a
whopping three days to shoot definitely
not a fun time on set and we can only
imagine how much the scene dragged on
for him but also when you're doing it
you're like you feel pretty in it i
guess number four seeing how david
harper gets along with co-stars on every
project he does we were quite surprised
to discover the one cast member he
loathed working with oh my god i hated
that dog this pooch was not david's best
friend in season one it would run off on
him a lot forcing production to do
multiple takes of all their scenes and
to make matters worse it seemed like its
trainer was in it for all the wrong
reasons i just remember the trainer come
on
we gotta make our money we would never
blame the poor pup for this one but due
to increasing frustrations from the
actor it was not asked to come back for
season 2. we hope it got a lot of treats
and maybe an emmy for his good boy
performance
number 5 you make me dizzy miss milly we
were just sitting and watching this and
even that made us sick millie bobby
brown divulged into what would be her
worst time filming a scene the scene in
question comes from season 3 episode 6
as 11 enters the chaotic mind of billy
and experiences a lot of twists and
turns of course they had to literally
twist and turn millie on a harness to
sell the effect what happens next well
she regretted it first of all and her
stomach did not appreciate it all that
flipping made her sick after the shoot
was over and let's just say we're happy
there's no behind the scenes video of
that
number six heights are a no-go for us
and for gaydon matarazzo it's a definite
terrifying time to go up against this
one comes from the infamous quarry scene
in season one episode six as dustin and
mike run away from their bullies they
get dangerously close to a cliff gayton
being sincere was not only concerned for
his own safety but for that of his
co-star finn wolfhard we can
wholeheartedly agree thank goodness
eleven was there to save the day kicking
butt yeah and still my hair is looking
like this yeah number seven how come no
one's lost their voice in stranger
things because we're surprised noah
schnapp didn't lose his in this scene
alone we can remember watching the
possession of will in season 2 and
barely being able to watch the
terrifying moment but all noah can
recall is having to scream a lot they
had to collect so many takes of just him
screaming that it really took a number
on his vocal cords but he's a
professional and he's willing to go that
extra mile
number eight we all saw this one coming
and joe kiri was not looking forward to
it they'd never done anything like this
it was like the fight day you know billy
and steve face off resulting in a not so
favorable outcome for steve he looked
seriously terrified of billy's rage and
that acting was more authentic than we
like to think very into this character
and he was very you know he was giving
it his all joe was actually terrified of
daker montgomery's acting in this moment
that the emotion really stuck with kyrie
after filming number nine a tearful
reunion between two friends always makes
for the perfect audience sob scene this
hard-hitting moment came from season 2
episode 7 when eleven reunites with
callie milly reported she could not keep
it together here and she really doesn't
like taking the emotions home offset but
it unfortunately did and it was hard of
her to let go of the heavy emotions
during the scene nobody likes crying
and we can only imagine how hard it was
for her to bounce back after this one i
feel like i don't need to go to therapy
anymore number 10 it's always surprising
to see that an unfavorable character is
the total opposite of their actor and as
we all know joe kiri is one of them he
recalls a moment in season one when
steve smashes jonathan's camera it made
us all really dislike his character and
he was right there with us kiri really
harps on hating these kinds of scenes
especially when it comes to bullying the
character of one of his best friends
behind the scenes charlie heaton i kind
of had a hard time sort of being mean to
charlie cause i love charlie so much he
doesn't have a mean bone in his body but
his character definitely thinks
otherwise
number 11 we can all recall that lovely
time when bowl cuts were the new trend
wow what an awful time stranger things
actually revived the ancient trend
forcing noah schnapp to rock one in
every scene it's one of the best
one the best things on television
and the worst he's definitely a little
too young to remember how cool it was to
have one so he was not enjoying the
little throwback he insisted every
season to restyle or cut it but
filmmakers were just not going to budge
noah was never able to understand the
style questioning why doesn't will maybe
he shaves his head like really did
everyone have that haircut in the 80s
number 12. uh oh could we be having a
little co-star drama on our hands nope
not really but watching your partner
kissing another person might be
uncomfortable and this was the case for
charlie heaton and natalya dyer as she
was kissing joe kiri in season 1. we can
imagine it was a little uncomfortable
for heaton to say the least but it seems
like there's no beat between him and joe
as their friendship seems to have moved
past it plus it looks like steve really
didn't get to have that relationship
after the first season so all that's in
the past now that's a whole lot of crazy
experiences for one big crazy show we'd
like to hope they had more favorite
scenes but it's hard to look past some
of these moments how awkward do you
think it really was for charlie heaton
you guys love the spoilers right
whose bright idea was it to send actors
on tours to promote the show and tell
them they're not allowed to talk about
the show what a scam well sometimes the
actors just let things slip ready to
find out who's the worst at keeping
secrets i'm gonna just say four rumors
about this season and then i want to see
your reaction number one uncomfy
contacts means one thing vecna during
netflix's official on the set of
stranger things video caleb mclaughlin
who plays lucas sinclair showed gayten
matarazzo a photo on his phone oh man
did they put contacts in you yeah were
they uncomfy yeah well usually contacts
wouldn't be a big deal caleb isn't one
to wear them for his character and this
season all of the contacts seem to be
associated with possession by vechna so
if that's not a spoiler we don't know
what is
number 2. all harnessed up with nowhere
to run after what happened with sadie
sync in the first half of season four we
can't help but feel that this post is a
major spoiler couldn't the selfie wait
noah of course there could be other
stunts in part two but we're skeptical
theory maybe vecna will go after all of
them at once and in a race to beat the
clock quite literally millie must stop
vacna to save her friends not a bad
theory right number three surely an
explosion is an innocent spoiler right
right out of fear of spoiling anything
again noah took down a photo of an
explosion taken while filming part two
of season four we're sure it's some sort
of spoiler when people were like you is
this a spoiler and i was like oh my god
i'm in trouble but hey once it's on the
internet good luck taking it down right
number four darn it gayten you're lucky
you were just so adorable or we might
have been angrier about this kaiten
matarazzo spoiled season 4's ending way
back in 2016. so the monster was a
recent test subject
number five at least finn didn't leak
hopper survival like netflix did while
it might not be a big spoiler it sure is
a season 4 spoiler of some description
we find out what happened to hopper this
season
okay number six honestly we were
grateful for the emotional preparation
that noah gave us he spoiled the death
of the dog in season three will's dog
chester i think he died didn't he
he did
number seven we've got confirmation for
returning characters in season five
joseph quinn may have just spoiled the
fate of his character eddie munson
hoping for a pair up between him and
charlie heaton's character jonathan
byers for season five and we doubt since
these two don't really know each other
that they could just be doing a cameo as
one of vecna's nightmare threats like
billy with max hey it could be a red
herring too who knows number eight it
would be a long season if these two
didn't see each other mike and eleven
are they gonna reunite oh
is this a spoiler once again it can
probably just be assumed this was going
to happen but hey half our cast wound up
in utah so
anything is possible number nine
surprise this season they're in a mall
shocking
noah spoiled the awesome location they
were filming at for season three we're
at the at the mall and then
um
the look on his face when he realized is
just priceless too yes noah is the one
who just can't keep the secrets to
himself he's called the tom holland of
stranger things by his co-stars because
he spoils so much number 10 this is why
only young people are allowed on
instagram david harbour went on
instagram live and promised fans he'd
read an excerpt of his script from
stranger things millie was watching
go back to work
did she ever sass him hard oh no millie
don't tell netflix no real spoilers were
given although he did pop up in his
television makeup not that that was any
surprise given it was already in the
trailer it's still problematic to go
live on set in costume though highly do
not recommend who knows what could
happen i'm just gonna read your sections
of the script milly number eleven is it
a spoiler or is he playing a terrible
poker face will we see eleven get her
powers back
but
yeah number twelve netflix you should
know better really sometimes netflix can
be just as bad as the actors they put
strict ndas on first off they spoiled
the fate of hopper in their trailer for
season four second because of course
part one ended on a cliffhanger with
nancy in the clutches of vecna well not
his creepy left hand but you know
possessed knowing what we know about how
this all works though the clock could be
ticking towards her doomsday so is it
really a spoiler
well it doesn't seem like any of the
stranger things actors have dethroned
the king of spoilers yet let's not
forget that tom holland literally
spoiled the biggest character demise in
all of the mcu maybe a young gayton
comes close do you think nancy dyer will
make it out alive let us know in the
comments and thanks for hanging out with
us here at the things
you